you might have to speak behind me just a
huge amount of press have gathered here
today this one of the first times that
we're really seeing kevin spacey over
the last few years since his career in
conduct has come under the spotlight in
court uh really mr spacey himself said
very little he was asked to give his
name
and his address he wasn't asked to enter
any sort of plea uh during this uh
hearing
of the charges that he is facing we
heard very little other than the sexual
assault charges took place uh in 2005
and 2013
uh the 2008 charge relates to uh causing
a man to engage in penetrative sexual
activity without uh consent much of this
hearing though really was relating to
whether uh kevin spacey
should be
made to surrender his travel document
whether he could be allowed to return uh
back to america where he's currently
living now his defense argued during the
hearing today that actually throughout
the proceedings he has completely
cooperated
with the investigation we heard how
there was four days
worth of police interviews that he
cooperated with in new york we know the
metropolitan police based on the
evidence that they have been gathering
these charges have uh now been brought
his legal team said he strenuously
denies
any wrongdoing and he's determined to
prove his evidence so they argued really
there is no need for mr spacey to
surrender his travel documents because
they said uh he needs to answer these
charges in order to proceed with his
life uh so kevin spacey the judge
decided in the end uh that he had the
the cps failed to persuade them uh that
he was uh at any risk that you could
just see behind me actually a bit of a
scrum as kevin spacey uh returns to his
car leaving the court today uh but as i
was saying cps uh failed to convince the
judge really that uh kevin spacey was
any sort of flight risk and the judge
now has granted him unconditional bail
and he will now be appearing at southern
crown court next on the 14th of july